[Music]
I'm Stuart brand from long now
and my wife and I live in the houseboat
community and Sausalito laundry tugboat
which we think is pretty salty yesterday
a voice came from the water and it was
tonight speakers swimming by from her
houseboat three docks over I also just
learned that she swam the escaped from
Alcatraz a race to this June and that is
salty
she's been basically bringing machines
closer to our senses closer to our mind
for years and now she's swimming
upstream to bring machines a lot closer
to our brains
Mary Lou Jepsen
it's great to be here uh no pressure
Stuart brand gave me a title for this
talk and I had to figure out the rest so
towards practical telepathy because it's
I think a really important moment to
understand what's happening in brain
computer communications the fidelity is
getting much better much faster than I
think a lot of you in the room may
appreciate and so with this lofty title
let me take a dive in trying to explain
to you where we're going and why I think
it's important to talk about it now so I
believe using the tools of our time
telepathy is in reach right now and the
tools of our time are Big Data machine
learning and the often neglected
trillion dollar manufacturing
infrastructure that makes today's
consumer electronics which is where I've
been living and breathing for the last
three decades shipping billions of
dollars worth of them and the fidelity
is going up and I think that you're
gonna you're gonna learn a lot from this
but I want to start with something some
of you might be thinking why is this not
fair enough why are we not a fraud
seriously you might not want to say it
but your might thinking yeah sure
telepathy you came to the talk but yeah
sure and so let's just start there okay
I've spent my entire life working on
this technology three decades and I and
my team and my investors will not ship a
product before its time but we believe
what we're inventing and creating can
save countless lives and transform the
lives of the living in a very positive
way which is why we're doing it but we
are not interested in the saccharine
extrinsic results of a hyper-connected
board shipping product before it's ready
or the valuation of the company we're in
it to do it and I just want to start
there so
um thanks uh so you know when I was a
teenager I fell in love with holography
this is very similar the first hologram
I made I actually couldn't find it but I
went on and on from there and the reason
I mentioned that is because I believe
holography is one of the three keys to
enable us to have a high resolution
brain-computer interface and so I spent
the next decade of my career trying to
make Holograms not in film but electro
holography and with a team of graduate
students somehow I found myself as at
MIT as a graduate student
we built the world's first fully
holographic video system all of us
together and I kept going with that and
and this holographic video system is the
crux of what we're using to see inside
of our bodies and brains upgraded thirty
thirty some odd years later and so
people talk about a world of screens and
it's just strange because I come from a
world of screens but I actually like I
literally like design the screens like
the liquid crystals the transistors the
drive schemes the devices they go into
the hardware the software every every
part of the system and I've been doing
that with all kinds of novel screen
technologies for my whole adult life
from virtual reality to projection
systems to HD TVs to wristwatch videos
to all kinds of different 3d systems
over the years and one example of this
and one of the reasons I have some
confidence to think that I can do what
we're talking about tonight
is some work that I did when I was a
professor at MIT and I started a
not-for-profit with my much more famous
co-founder Nicholas Negroponte a picture
here with the late Kofi Annan when he
was head of the United Nations and so we
decided that if we could make $100
laptop we could lower the cost of the
laptop so much we could get it on mass
to children in the developing
being whirled who lacked really good
good teachers and a lot of lacked asacs
access to education basically we throw
away half the children that are born in
the world and that they don't get really
access to a good education so the titans
of industry thought we were nuts
got thrown out of MIT for doing it they
did say you know look get it out of your
system first then come back it just
looks a lot like a startup they knew it
was an unfair profit but you know we did
it we made $100 laptop made a
not-for-profit with a few billion
dollars of revenue catalyzed 30 billion
dollars of revenue for our for-profit
partners became the fastest-growing
consumer electronic category ever
recorded and oh yeah transform the lives
of hundreds 100 million children in the
developing world and at that point I
just sort of thought you know there
aren't enough MIT professors sleeping on
the factory floor is the of the world to
design really innovative things that can
ship like universities ship students and
papers but if you want to ship something
you have to work with the infrastructure
so I moved to Asia and so this is like
the factories that I've live in breathe
in this is final assembly when you take
all the components you've developed and
bring them together I also work a lot in
the factories that make different chips
and components and so forth to design
that to get that functionality so um
what else can you make with these things
I mentioned I left MIT and I did a
startup and and then Sergey Brin kind of
aqua hired me and my startup and I went
to Google and I thought you know wow
what if everybody could have a
million-dollar view or a shared screen
to see and interact with their family in
a different time zone wouldn't that be
cool and how would you do that and I
can't actually say what I did at Google
but I can write what a patent sir and so
basically LCDs liquor crystal displays
are like $20 a square foot and I figured
out how to architect the liquor crystal
display is such that you could just tile
screens together and not see any
boundaries between them and then put a
3d into it so things would be at
infinity so you could all you know have
the view of the beach or the
or the eiffel tower away whatever you
wanted and or or your your family in a
different place
from there I went to oculus and this is
sort of the last trip because a few
years ago about five years ago virtual
reality and augmented reality got hot
again and I had a lot of experience in
VR AR 1.0 and this is still like a face
box a sort of face mask or a shoebox on
your head and that seems kind of large
so again I can't say when it's it an
oculus in face book because that secret
but obviously you want you know there's
one thing that's acceptable to wear on
your face and it better look like
glasses or it's not gonna have
widespread acceptance and so I figured
out how to make a an AR or I wrote
patent an oculus owns a lots of patents
actually I have like more than 200
patents in the last I haven't counted in
a long time but like a few years ago I
counted so I invent a lot and ship the
inventions which is how I publish and so
this looks like a light-filled display
it's not I use the old seamlessly Thai
label trick from my Google days on the
back of your retina and that enabled a
VR AR system that toggles with the right
resolution with vergence control and a
lot of the things that you hear about
with the RNA are as issues which are
totally solvable but at that time I and
my colleagues at Apple and Google and
and Microsoft and Sony and magically
been so forth or able to pull up
something I thought was more interesting
we were able to put manufacturing
process improvements into this
trillion-dollar manufacturing supply
chain at the sort of bottom of it I sort
of think of it as like this trickle down
of Moore's Law hitting the lowly
factories that I've lived and breathed
in in the LCD fabs liquid crystal
display about some camera chip fabs and
the discontinuity of Moore's Law the the
idea that Gordon Moore the founder of
Intel said transistor density will
double every 18 months and that's been
true for 50 years or
more really had a big impact in a
discontinuity in the physics as the
pixel size approached s-- the wavelength
of light and that's why I mentioned the
holography in the beginning you can
record a hologram if your pixel size is
approximately the wavelength of light
every single one of you in this room
that has a smartphone has camera chip in
it with one micron pixels which is the
wavelength of light in the near-infrared
and your body is translucent to the
near-infrared the visible is a little
bit shorter wavelength and I thought you
know this is just too big of an idea not
to quit my job because she job at
Facebook and try to figure out if I
could make a system that could see in
high resolution inside of our bodies and
brain so that was two and a half years
ago I quit and started open water
actually a mutual friend of ours Peter
Gabriel though the the musician rock
star human rights activist I think he
called me like every week for like six
months trying to convince me to quit to
do with this outside of Facebook so
anyway ultimately he named the company
open water
I actually didn't swim open water I just
started swimming open water because I
thought it would be pretty funny for
somebody that has a company called open
water to swim open water because it'd
just be really confusing so I found it I
find enjoyable but the goal what we're
trying to do is to take this big iron
machine this big MRI machine and reduce
it into a consumer electronics wearable
and that can transform medical energy
and it can also transform the way we
communicate with each other via brain
and and let me take you on this journey
and explain to you why I think so
I believe that we can put the
functionality of that MRI system into a
wearable into a ski hat or a bandage or
a bra or many different things that
gives not just MRI resolution but
readwrite and higher resolution at
massively lower cost
not just in 10x lower cost like with one
laptop per child but at scale
1,000 times cheaper which can be really
transformative and so why does that
dovetail not just with medical imaging
but understanding our brains because our
brains are part of our body so if we can
see inside of our body we can see inside
of our brains and there's a lot of great
work that I'm going to share with you
tonight by these amazing neuro
scientists using functional magnetic
resonance imaging scanners those are
like the video form of MRI showing all
kinds of things that we can communicate
by just lying inside of these machines
so the National Academies have said of
the top five of most the National
Academies of most developed countries
have said of the top five things you can
do as a technologist reverse engineering
the brain is one of those things and so
the question is you know how do you do
that so in the last two-and-a-half years
I'm not a neuroscientist I've talked to
a lot of neuroscientists any
neuroscientist worth their salt will
tell you we don't even know what a
thought is like you know sort of like
pornography you know when you see it we
don't know what it is and this whole
issue boils down to something they call
causal versus non causal you have about
a hundred billion neurons in your brain
each of them with a hundred thousand
possible connections and it just seems
intractable to track that and that's
just the neurons let alone the glia and
whatever's happening in your gut and the
hormones and all of this stuff going on
and then there's the non-causal approach
where you just do a top-down approach
which is really I think what's happened
with some of the both the implant
solutions and the fMRI solutions and so
I think that there's this context that
that you know the Bottoms Up approach is
pretty cool but the top-down approach is
also pretty cool and hopefully we meet
in the middle and so I want to talk to
you about a little bit about what's been
done with fMRI in 1991 got the cover of
science a group at Harvard Mass General
Hospital was able to show that the blood
flow of your brain as measured in an
fMRI machine could show whether you were
looking
not an image or not first thing amazing
oh my gosh can we use fMRI to see
thoughts well if we fast forward a
number of years later I became aware of
this work this is the work of Professor
Jack gallant at University of California
at Berkeley and he started working with
lab rats and then macaques and then
moved up to using graduate students as
lab rats and put them in MRI scanners
for hundreds of hours and made them
watch youtube videos where recordings
were made of their minds lighting up or
not lighting up area by area what fMRI
measures is oxygen use by looking at the
color change or the change of blood
properties whether it's carrying oxygen
or not under - under a huge magnetic
field and by looking at at that and
creating a library if you will of
students reacting to hundreds of hours
of YouTube videos then a new clip was
shown called the presented clip here and
the computer using the scan data
inferred what it thought the student was
looking at and the result is a grainy
image of what the student was looking at
and I saw this and I'm like oh my gosh
we just have to lower the the size of
the device and up the resolution and
there you go and I tried I tried to get
Google their funders I tried to get
Facebook anyway I am doing it now and it
started so it's been a long haul and you
know also there's this Japanese group
who went even further they put the
graduate students in the MRI machines
and woke the students up a couple of
minutes after they fell asleep asked
them what they were dreaming about to
make a video of your dreams so that you
can dump your dreams in an MRI scanner
to the computer it's totally cool
this is a back to UC Berkeley and with
less than 5 percent on false positive
threshold by looking at an area or a
signature of your brain we can predict a
word cloud of words you're thinking in
this case numbers in another case
there's a there's a violence area sex
and violence area so you could actually
in the future imagine turning that
filter down if you didn't wish to
communicate
so sex and violence now that you know
you're working your brains up with each
other so this is pretty cool stuff and
there's there's some work done this work
is a decade ago this is just a very fast
path through fMRI where the students
were shown a thousand images and the
computer could if the students were
shown each of the thousand images just
twice with 80% accuracy the fMRI machine
and the computer could decide or gasps
or infer what the student what student
what the images the student was looking
at and just to be clear through random
gasps with a thousand images that's a
point one percent chance of happening
this is pretty stunning how accurate you
can get in certain control in certain
situations just using fMRI so then
there's a lot of work that's gone on
with with brain implants and it's got to
be pretty tough for you to have the
brain implant um has anybody ever had
brain surgery in the room I have okay so
I the only startup doing brain computer
communication that's not doing implement
in plants I had a non-elected brain
surgery in 1995 to stay alive but take a
dozen medications every day to live
you're gonna do that if it's that or
death but I just don't see a billion
people having elective brain surgery
anytime soon it's the hardest thing I've
ever eaten in my life
but yet you know here's a case at Brown
University my alma mater
where a woman was a paraplegic they gave
her an implant and for the first time
she could give herself a drink with a
robot arm totally cool so if you've got
a condition where you can tree or lock
in or you can't move I totally see it
there's been this amazing work done with
electrode probes where 500 neurons were
activated in this in this primate and
with those 500 neurons
activating the electrical pulses the
primate could play the video game and do
pretty well and then they gave the they
hooked three primates together each with
500 neuro 500
and the three primates play the video
games a lot better which is really kind
of interesting if you think of where
that where that might lead it was
sharing our minds and so the bat we're
making I'm making is that the massively
more data we enable by putting a 2-ton
magnet that's the most expensive room in
the hospital that costs a few million
dollars that has liquid helium to cool
it in a power plant to run it on the
magnetic shielding and no metal and all
of that we put that into a wearable we
can get massively more data higher
resolution which I'm going to talk about
how with better temporal response and we
also have found and I'm going to talk a
little bit about non-invasive actually
direct neuron read/write and better
hierarchical algorithms that we think we
can develop with us non causally sort of
top-down meeting the bottom-up people
who are saying we don't know what a
thought is there's a hundred billion
neurons each with a hundred thousand
different connections we hear you we
also think it's important to come
top-down so we're replacing that big
honking literally big iron machine with
a wearable and for the first year and a
half I convinced my investors to just
you know let's not focus on product
let's just look at the limits of the
physics can we hit the resolution of
fMRI which is about ten cubic
millimeters and then can we get to one
millimeter which is about the resolution
of non-video MRI we did that we did that
and we found the limit was at a couple
of microns we could focus through skull
and brain simulated optically mimicking
phantom of skull and brain to a few
microns which is it sounds like a
thousand times better it's a like about
a five thousandth of a millimeter but
that's actually an XY and Z so that's a
thousand times a thousand times a
thousand or a billion times higher
resolution than MRI that our core
technology is capable of and if we
combine that with work that's been done
with neurons
we can see the optical changes in
neurons before an electrical pulse
proceeds down the axon and a neuron
that's because the ionic channels change
and it causes the membranes to roughen
and when they rough and they scatter and
we can see a difference from that and
it's also been shown that you can use
near-infrared light to write the state
of the neuron without even optogenetics
there's also the combination of the
great work of opto genetics where you
add a tag to a neuron where you can
optically excite it so we think that we
could get a lot more information and so
then we get to this question and it's a
yes/no question do we or don't we want
to understand the brain and you could
say no we don't want to I've had a lot
of people arguing and I just like well
really you know the National Academy is
most developed countries have say it as
I said earlier that this is one of the
things you can do as a technologist to
really transform but we could decide we
do not want to understand our brains or
any other brains on the planet at all it
feels like burying your head in the sand
we might be too scared of it but
ultimately I can't imagine how we don't
want to do it and so on some level we're
really all Stephen Hawking in that the
input to our brains are pretty good the
eyes and ears have pretty high bandwidth
but what comes out you know we move our
tongues and speak or type I mean if I
was a good dancer maybe I could
communicate but I'm not and you know
we're stuck with language and what if we
could dump the images the raw emotion
the memories the layers of music
directly out of our brains into each
other what could we do then is a
question and then the flipside is you
know can we handle it this is a classic
Star Trek the first generation Spock was
this guy it was half human and half its
called Vulcan it was very logical I mean
getting these mind melds where he's the
only guy that could mind Mel but he was
just he'd fall in a heap afterwards and
not be able to work for three days
because all of the emotion was just way
too much for him and so
I wonder how we will be able to handle
it as we are able to share these
thoughts and we're going to talk a
little bit about the ethics of that so
where are we today I've explained a
little bit about that and where can we
got in 10 20 30 years is really a
question and I might be more Pro on that
this can happen faster than some of you
but pick a year it's gonna happen in 10
to 20 years I think we'll see language
decline and our ability to share
audio-visual fluency increase an
emotional understanding of each other
should increase with our ability to
share this the thoughts and memories
that we wish that give us this great joy
that we wish to share with people and
then we become somewhat transparent it's
it's this last bastion of privacy and
how do we handle being able to see each
other's thoughts and dreams so even if
you think no way 10 20 years like this
is the long now like take a year like
these before the clock runs out or out
you know like it's going to happen it's
inevitable and you know the big
opportunity really might be going
bullying and biases and power trips and
stuff like that because we can see
through it hopefully so I think that as
we think about connecting ourselves with
high-bandwidth it's perhaps inevitable
that we will only exist as part of a
collective and what does that look like
and how do we walk into that the Native
Americans have had this vision of making
decisions based on what would happen
seven generations from now but we're
living at a time where in seven
generations will any of us alive today
recognize if we could live that long
that as humanity with all of the changes
in biotechnology in front of us right
now and maybe that's the wrong question
anyway isn't humanity kind of
discriminatory we're not the only living
things on earth and isn't it the life
cycle and don't we care more about that
as we become more connected to each
other so
that's the vision so you know what do we
want this is San Francisco
so peace love and understanding but you
know what do we got you know we've got
you know power control ambition ego and
how does that switch or change as our
brains come on line with each other
so do we use it to empower leaders or do
we even need leaders can we communicate
without them these are these are
questions that we need to think about
but you know we have gotten better you
know if you think pick a year thousand
years ago 10,000 years ago it really was
might makes right and you know now we
have floss that you know murder is a
crime and stuff like that so it's it's
much better but maybe the big the really
big thing that we should be doing is
working on you know the innovative
solutions to big problems with really
big impact and that's the most valuable
thing in the world and by putting our
brains together we should surely be able
to solve these better if we could do
that effectively and so the world they
say is only changed with small groups
what if we could make the group's bigger
without losing bound with like we do now
and could what could we do that and it
said you know primates only have have
three times less connections outside of
their family group than humans and that
study was done before social media and
yes there are parallels and learnings we
can have from social media here another
thought I had as I was listening
recently to an interview the fabulous
Rob Reid did with Martin Rees which I'd
highly recommend and in it Martin Rees
said you know Darwinism was a survival
of the fittest obviously but
characterized by two things intelligence
and aggression together survive and as
we connect our minds more together just
connectivity Trump's sorry for the word
aggression and that's the opportunity or
the the lack of one so to open water and
what we're doing consumer electronics
big data machine
this is some of what can happen with it
I did a start-up because universities
well I got thrown out for shipping stuff
like university ships students and
papers anything else is a product can't
do it I want to do it at scale I use the
trillion dollar manufacturing
infrastructure of Asia which means I
have to ship B companies the big
powerful companies are really the ones
that today are really known for
optimizing click revenue for ad sales
and they're really good at it it made
everybody a lot of money but the
decisions are made by people that are
really good at that and web services and
so things on their fringes tend to
require a semi almost unanimous decision
by the the stakeholders and there's a
lot of politics I mean sort of the the
lust for power and control that gets in
the way and startups are just so simple
you just go down to Sand Hill Road
somebody gives you money there's more
money for startups than ever before in
recorded history and then you just
execute and you show what you've got and
then somebody else gives you more money
and it just seems like a simpler
structure to get going it was just
faster and more efficient so we're
trying to use a start-up structure to do
the innovators dilemma classic Clayton
Christensen that says you know honestly
those big MRI machines haven't improved
much in 30 years and the trickle down of
Moore's law hitting these camera chip
fabs just seemed like a really important
opportunity to explore and so I'm going
to show you a little bit about how this
works over here because we use basically
red light to see inside of our bodies
and brains and yeah I've got a little
setup here so if we can turn down the
lights for a sec I just want to show
maybe I'll go over here um our red light
goes right through my hand and my body
so does x-rays so two gamma rays so does
it two ton magnet but guess which one's
cheaper buy a lot so um special for the
long now my husband and I
found a place with brains yesterday pig
brains so I have a trigger warning is
anybody a vegetarian no seriously
yeah sooo yeah so I got brains because I
wanted to show you since we're talking
about brains and it's Halloween so this
was petaluma yesterday and I was really
surprised so this is um this is a brain
and this is this is two pigs brains um
and I've got some more back here but I
implanted a tumour backstage can
everybody see the tumor in the pig's
brain it's the dark spot so what this
shows is that you can see tumors with
just red light but I have some more
brain here and if I put it on top I'm
just spreading it out it's really
uh you can you can no longer see the
tumor and it's just the light scatters
everywhere and and in order to be able
to see the tumor we have to figure out a
way to de scatter the light and the heat
of doing that and why mention holography
oops
is-is-is holography it enables us to
record the intensity of the light the
phase of the light lights a wave at
every angle simultaneously including at
every angle of the scattering of the
brain or the body and so we use that and
a third key ultrasonic pings
that are now we can make in chips and so
this this picture of this head this
these three disks represent the camera
chips and ultrasonic chips and light
that were making the new kinds of lasers
that we're making and from one of these
disks that represents the ultrasonic
chip in the camera chip an ultrasonic
ping emerges and focuses down to a spot
then I'm gonna let the light in and
you're probably wondering well why the
light later and it's like it's a very
simple reason when you when you hear it
the speed of sound is slower than the
speed of light and so we want them to
end up at the same place at the same
time so we bring in the light scatters
everywhere or the like the brain or like
through my hand and the light that goes
through that focus of the ultrasonic
ping changes color ever so slightly just
like the pitch of a police car siren
changes as it speeds past you it Doppler
shifts and so we exploit another
property of holography which is only two
beams of exactly the same color light
can record a hologram in interference
fringes which is really what a whole one
beam can't record a hologram you need to
beat two beams across each other and
that creates this fringe structure which
we decode and we decode that frame
structure much like rosalind Franklin
decoded this iconic image of x-ray
diffraction to reveal the structure of
DNA for the first time
but we can do that in a million times a
second because we're using camera chips
and electronics and not film and so
forth and so then we take another
another black disc and focus another
ping down and in fact using this
principle we can scan out spot by spa
box'll by voxel a 3d pixel of the brain
raster scanning row by row or randomly
in different ways or focusing on areas
of interest we can do it with large foci
or small foci and this enables us to
scan both the brain and our body so
you're probably thinking what about
skull and bones and so this is this is
this is real human skull that someone on
my team got at skulls unlimited calm
yeah you know we had fun in the lab um
so uh this is just red light goes right
through those of you who are in optics
know um you know black absorbs light
white scatters it so it just scatters
and so we use that and with that we've
taken phantoms like this where we
implant tumors and we can find the
tumors the vasculature that has this has
the same optical properties as flesh and
we're able to find things with the same
optical properties as tumors and
vasculature and so forth and so we've
been doing a lot of that we used to use
whatever was on sale in the meat market
and some of the team protested because
the lab started to stink a lot after we
run it scan overnight so anyway we're
finding different tumors and this is
super key here's a flask of blood which
you can see and what's really
interesting is red light the blood is
absorbed the the blood absorbs the red
light and if I compare that to my pound
of flesh here it scatters it so you can
see the difference of that and so can
our camera chips and that's super
important when we think about our bodies
because any tumor bigger than a
millimeter or two in size steals blood
and grows vasculature so it can grow
try to kill you so tumors have five
times the amount of blood as normal
tissue that's a top killer cancer
cardiovascular disease we're really good
at seeing where blood isn't like in
clogs in your heart or veins or so forth
and really importantly the color change
blood makes whether it's carrying oxygen
or not carrying oxygen which is exactly
what fMRI functional magnetic resonance
imaging does which is where I showed you
in the beginning
throwing graduate students into those
machines we could read their dreams
they're the images in their head the
words they were thinking of and so forth
so we can do that literally with camera
chips a laser and ultrasonic pings in in
the form of a wearable so this is a
mock-up of what our system can look like
and you can wear it here around your
head different things we're building we
also might go with a wand kind of system
you know we're working on different
different form factors for that but the
physics is pretty solid there's also
something with with fMRI it often takes
four seconds to see the the the use what
we're looking at is where oxygen is used
in your brain as I mentioned and that's
basically the blood flowing by the
oxygen gets pulled off and then it's
they call it deoxygenated no more oxygen
on the blood but there's a dip that
happens first so we should be able to
see a sub-second response we're also
looking at neurons as I mentioned which
move in a millisecond kind of timeframe
and so we're combining all of these to
see what kinds of systems we can build
so last winter spring we had this big
lab rig setup where I was able we were
able I work with this fantastic team I'm
up here tonight but I really you know
the work of all of the team that I work
with is his astonishing best team I've
ever had that had the joy to work with
we built this system and we built it
because before you as a chip designer
when you take when you design chips you
need to spend millions of dollars
to get access to the fabs and if you
don't ship those chips in short order
after designing them you're thrown out
of that lab and so what you do is you
jerry-rigged whatever you can use an
existing chip so you can test every
aspect of your design with a big rig
first and make sure your system will do
what you think it does so we spent two
and a half years doing that and now what
we've done is we've collaborated and
made these these new components with
partners three new components camera
chips ultrasonic chips and new kinds of
lasers the camera chips
I talked about the one micron feature
size is is key what happens is the light
and the infrared light that comes in is
converted at 70 percent efficiency to
electrons that's up 10x in the last year
alone
and that's become standard in
smartphones to do 3d sensing and for
next-generation augmented reality so
that you can play pokemon go plus plus
no seriously that's why billion dollars
was spent to do this so that you could
play pokemon go plus plus and and to
unlock your phone by not you know typing
a password or you know swiping a pattern
but I thought that maybe we could use in
a different way so we are and there's
it's also very good do you know how many
lasers are in this generation iPhone
close to 500 because they put dot and
line patterns on you to figure out what
your face looks like so we can just use
that to enable telepathy and to
massively lower the cost of medical
imaging which I thought might be more
interesting and it's not like look I
liked like stood him up games when I was
15 - and I worked with a lot of people
at oculus that still love him but you
know I just it's fine because it's
enabled us to get this technology
available and the ultrasonic chips that
really I think the first time that came
to my consciousness of some work that
Texas Instruments did in the early 90s
to make screens projectors so that you
could plug a laptop into a projector in
a board
rather than printing out your slides it
used to be you'd have an over read
protector and what they called foils
which were pieces of plastic that were
printed on and you project your talk
that way and what Texas Instruments did
was make pixels with little diving
boards on each pixel that were
electrostatically deflected so that
technology now 30 years later is
enabling us to ultrasonically vibrate
and focus with these chips that we can
make in any fab that can steer around
plus or minus 60 degrees to allow us to
focus into the head and change the
wavelength of the light the other part
on one of the reasons we've scanned
mostly dead animals whatever was on sale
at the meat market or optically
mimicking phantoms is because we're
alive it's good to be alive that means
we move we breathe and blood moves
through our veins and that's the thing
that we have to do a flash or strobe
faster than the blood moving through
there are veins although I'm friends
with this professor in the Netherlands
that has graduate students but
tourniquets on their arms to stop the
blood flow so that you can take images
with normal lasers but if you did that
on your neck
it's called strangulation and yeah I
really won't work so we did the hard
thing we made a post laser with the
right what's called coherence very very
fine control the colors when we shift
the color only the shifted color
interfere it's not the unshifted that's
called coherence and at the right
wavelengths so we can pick up the color
change in blood whether it's oxygenated
or not so we've made those and we also
like in the last six months we've
lowered the amount of light we need by
about 10x we've increased the image
quality as measured by the
signal-to-noise ratio which is a
technical term but basically you want
more signal less noise so that's good
we've reduced the foot put down by about
a hundred X and we're about to in this
quarter increase the scan speed by about
a hundred X and so the system and
build-out right now is in a small animal
facility locally at a secret undisclosed
location where we've actually slimmed
- just a little ultrasonic array the
optical detector camera unit and a
little fiber-optic probe it comes in on
the rat total ethical approval to do
this all of our stuffs ours all of our
tests our tests are checked and our goal
this quarter next quarter is to MRI
these little rats and then image them
and make sure our images are the same or
better than the MRIs and then we'll get
approval for human use so this is super
important not just for telepathy I keep
mentioning but it bears to mention again
two-thirds of humanity lacks access to
medical imaging it can be transformative
to let us see and diagnose conditions
earlier and treat them earlier but
everyone in this room say well that's
you know poor people well it's true for
rich people too we know MRI is a better
diagnostic about 10 times better for
breast cancer but do we use it for
routine screening in the u.s. no does it
used in any country in the world no
what's the number one reason why it's
too expensive so if we can lower the
cost of it then people worry about false
positives and it's like when the scan
cost less than a dollar you can scan all
the time you should be able to buy this
thing in the drugstore and just scan if
you've got the bracketing do you have to
go all Angela Jolie or could we make a
bra where you really cut off part of
your body and you know it's serious
stuff can we just look at overtime the
deltas you care basically about three
things is it getting bigger
is it getting smaller is it staying the
same size if it's getting bigger you
might want to seek active care but if
it's something you can just watch it
which is very different than what we
have now with the cost structures
involved there's also a limit to how
much gadolinium you can have which is
the contrast agent that's injected for
an MRI scan and it's thought now to
cause cancer and people are trying to
figure out what that means for lifetime
scans obviously with CT and Pat there's
radiation there so you're also limited
so then the other thing the most
expensive healthcare in the world is
that for brain disease which two billion
people suffer
if you add up things like schizophrenia
and depression and neurodegenerative
diseases like Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's and this could do enormous
good for that like there's there's a
biological basis for brain disease right
now to diagnose depression where the
average person loses 12 years of work in
their life that's clinically depressed
you answer these questions like have you
gained weight
are you sleeping all the time are you
tired do you have thoughts of suicide
you answer to that yes to that and 50
other questions you're clinically
depressed
we're studies have shown that actually
the way your that what your brain looks
like an MRI is an indicator of what kind
of depression or if you have depression
and from that you can see what the
therapy does does this pill work to
change that pattern or not you can see
that much more efficiency you can close
the loop precision psychology could be
enabled through this and then Peter
Gabriel who I mentioned earlier is I
just want it like as we sort of start to
bring this together we're doing imaging
and also some some write ability that
I'll talk about if what if we combine
this with all the great work being done
in genomics and blood is there a way and
Peter asked and I think he started and
he's announced this thing that he
started called the tap which is a way to
think about he talks about the music
industry fundamentally changing when
streaming music happened a music got
cheaper but B everybody got access and
so how do we get everybody to have
access we probably do have enough
doctors they're not evenly distributed
there's three continents that lack
enough doctors and yet smartphones have
happened in all of this stuff so how do
we sort out what that looks like and I'm
so glad he's taking it on we're helping
him everybody can but one thing that
that didn't occur to me on the focused
ultrasound foundation I was just there
last week helped me understand that
these sonic pings were focusing down for
a microsecond and then we shift the
wavelength of light if we just focus
that for 15 seconds we can do surgery
without a knife we can ablate tissue
open the blood-brain barrier we can do
neuromodulation we can deliver drugs
sort of like micro dosing but the right
dose at the right place and not getting
the drug everywhere else by using drugs
that are basically micro encapsulated
and the ultrasound bursts them and so
this is approved for essential tremor
for treatment of Parkinson's disease the
recovery rate if you don't guess what if
you don't cut up in your body and bleed
out blood is much higher and so it turns
out that from where I said that's like
sorry I'm an electrical engineer that's
a packaging problem if you want to put
in that much power for 15 million times
longer than we are but it's at the same
basic power density so we're very
excited about that
on FDA we're in some informal
discussions with them but the predicate
products that have existed using
near-infrared light are for many decades
as well as ultrasound you're exposed to
more infrared light today on the streets
of San Francisco even in the clouds if
you're in a foggy part then you will be
with our system and the ultrasonic pings
are well understood as well so we don't
anticipate much of a problem
we're walking through it so what this
can enable is the democratization of
healthcare and telepathy which brings me
to not to do tonight in Stuart's title
because they're not separable the same
device can do both the software layer is
different but the same device that sees
inside of our bodies can see inside of
our brains and so in terms of the limits
of speed we can go up to a hundred
thousand frame per second per unit and
we can multiplex them which is way
faster than MRI although our first units
will be substantially slower as we walk
through developing this in terms of
depth we had gotten to six inches but
then we up to the laser power it's
really a function of laser power so if
you think about an obese patient the
limits from the FDA are basically how
much how much infrared per centimeter
squared and this might sound cruel but
an obese person
more surface area than a skinny so you
can basically irradiation or light and
get more depth so we think about a foot
from any side we're walking through that
right now resolution we can match fMRI
we can go smaller we could even go as we
showed in the lab and live on stage at
Ted this year we could get a few micron
resolution the blood timescale is about
four seconds we think we can bring that
down to sub-second looking at the dip as
I said but there's also the neural
timescale and how many neurons we scan
over the course of milliseconds as they
beep is beep they they send electrical
pulses we think of them as I think of
them as sound and and we're not working
on causality not all hundred billion
neurons are saying we can come from a
top-down approach and meet the bottom-up
people and it reminded me a lot as I was
preparing this talk of talks I had with
the amazing Paul Allen co-founder of
Microsoft founder of the Allen Institute
who died too early a few weeks ago and
he always used to tell me I was nuts
which I always like talking to people
that told me that cuz I tend to learn
something especially somebody as smart
as Paul such a great loss but he would
always say you know there's five Nobel
prizes just to understand how a neuron
works I'd say great Paul you guys go get
those Nobel prizes and we'll meet you
halfway and there's just this
monoculture of neuroscience that you've
got to understand the electrical pulses
down then I'm an electrical engineer I
get it but there's all this stuff you
can do with optics and physics and in
fact that is what we're using for
imaging systems it's the physics
breakthroughs that have enabled us to
see through our bodies so the best
argument I heard a friend sent me a
paper who shall remain nameless I'm
saying you know what you're doing sounds
like this is again the causal approach
there was this classic paper written two
years ago about you know new
neuroscience approach could it work sort
of decoding what was happening on a
silicon microprocessor driving the game
donkey kong and could you like probe out
the transistors and figure out how
donkey
worked and they tried to probe them out
and then they zapped a transistor at a
time and the result was they couldn't
figure it out it just didn't work it was
it's pretty cool paper but they do point
out in this paper the brain is more
modular and so we still know with 80%
accuracy what image you're looking at
with a 5 percent false negative what
kind of word cloud you're thinking of
just from existing resolution of fMRI
scanners and so the implications are
profound for that again we're not trying
to say we're doing causal we're doing
non-causal and there's profound ethics
for this one question is can you assume
with what someone's thinking you can do
that now but we're not saying we're 99%
accurate so question is how do we filter
have you ever had a thought you didn't
want to communicate to somebody but
couldn't suppress it yeah so we're gonna
need filters as I mentioned the sex and
violence filter people are working on
but you know other filters because you
know we don't want to be rude and then
what do we do with the data and we were
talking in the green room before about
Elinor Ostrom and the work she did in
land trust she's the only woman that won
the Nobel Prize in Physics so far and
she really worked on you know as we
think of having all of this data how do
we deal with it responsibly because that
what I think is gonna happen is it's
gonna start with low resolution grainy
and it's gonna get better and then all
of a sudden it's gonna be really great
and then why did you sign away with
their data before like what you know
we've seen this movie before with social
media now maybe so how do we get smart
to that and talk about that now and form
the right construct to how to deal with
all of this data because we'll have lots
more with success imagine we have way
more medical energy and data than
everything that exists today and you
know pick a number of years again I
think it's a single digit small you
might think it's longer but how do we
define the rules for this how do we deal
with trolls or is there an effective way
and why belong to this and
Elinor Ostrom so like when if you the
can there was a famous paper called the
tragedy of Commons that was written they
thought like you know somebody can just
buy extra cows and over grain / graze
the the grass and there'd be no grass
for anybody and or the use of water but
you know the examples shown in in Bali
or in these small communities is that
they actually had very good ways of
handling it and it's locally and in
talking and I think this community might
really help us figure out the right way
to go about this but it's our job to
define what it means to be responsible
before we ship a product which is why
we're talking about it here legal
proceedings of course the answer is no
however you there's a book called I know
what you're thinking which shows how
already how fmri have been used to
incarcerate people in various countries
already so privacy just a question do
you think you'd be more private if you
had an implant or if you could remove
something in the form of a wearable
should be obvious so the apps I'm just
gonna go super quickly brain body can't
separate a movie director suppose you're
a movie director and you wake up with an
idea for a new scene that you're gonna
shoot that day but you had a new idea
could you just dump a rough cut of it
directly from your head so your team and
say you know I know we're gonna shoot
that other thing this would be so much
better can we do it it's a fast way to
communicate visually for so many people
enhance social media is obviously
another application for this as we think
about really collecting setting our
brain to rest mode we know that that
seems to be the cause of a lot of mental
disease people meditate but is there an
easier way to do that and could we
enable that dumping the words out of
your brain without having to type or
seems very easy just from the center of
the center of where the word center is
and in your brain a lot of people ask me
about gaming and digital therapeutics
and there's great work being done on
that I think it might be an interim
solution as we get to more like I don't
know if we need the games anymore
I know maybe that's controversial but
can you erase thoughts bad memories
maybe but you know you could do that now
by stopping part of your brain and
there's some implications if the brain
with I mean we do do deep brain
stimulation already don't know brain
after death it's a lot easier to record
while you're alive especially if you're
looking at blood flow but a lot of
people ask me we don't know i we don't
know how to do that but to share the joy
of a new memory would be pretty amazing
to do with your grandkids or to capture
that and share all of the emotion of it
this might be the biggest moneymaker of
them all I think people would pay
anything and you know what it doesn't
have to be that good like really to
start even just knowing they were your
pet your dog or cat was anxious it was
hungry or wanted to walk you know it'd
be pretty didn't like that other dog
like that you know it'd be really
helpful sex and intimacy I mean right
now we Stroke body parts and release
oxytocin what would happen if we could
share the joy the emotion the
vulnerability and so forth and do I need
to go further maybe over drinks later
but you get the idea I think this is
inevitable it's really inevitable
because of what's happened in the
trillion dollar manufacturing
infrastructure machine learning and big
data I think it's inevitable we hope
that we are the company that enables it
but more importantly we want it to
happen which is why we're talking about
it because it's important it happens
people are dying so you know if you're a
doubter still do you really think having
more data at higher resolution at better
temporal future with readwrite neurons
will not give us more information to
understand this especially as we
massively lower the cost and put it in a
wearable rather than the most expensive
rooms in hospitals so and again it's
inevitable because you could even say no
brain computer interface we just can't
deal with it we can't deal with the
ethics
but in the case of what we're doing it's
the same hardware layer that can see
inside of our bodies in their brains
they're all biological and so it's very
hard to separate and so my question to
you if you buy that argument what can we
do to shape it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay we're all gonna just think about
this for about an hour and then they'll
talk okay um one thing I didn't get
which is I sort of get how the brain
reading part goes how does the brain
writing part go we can neuromodulator
the focused ultrasound at a longer
amount of time and that's very helpful
for brain disease right now but we can
also do that with neurons and change the
state of neurons and so that gets to the
causality we can write the state
certainly with optogenetics which is the
tag of a often optically sensitive part
where you're genetically changing your
material but even without genetically
changing the material the the indicators
that we have are that there's there's a
lot of literature published that using
infrared light alone you can stimulate
neurons or inhibit neurons and since we
can focus that light non-invasively
through skull and brain and focus it to
the diameter of the neuron we're making
the leap to say we should be able to do
this so presumably the first application
so that kind of writing would be medical
and what things come to mind like
Parkinson's or what sir deep brain
stimulation is used for Parkinson's also
for essential tremor other other brain
disease issues mental disease there now
and it's fda-approved so let us see
angle is you're saying with the pet it
can be probably pretty low bandwidth and
both sides will fake it with humans
well it's interesting I'm suddenly
thinking Marshall McLuhan the difference
between cold and hot and cool and hot
and they thought that sort of low
bandwidth people like you like girls
with glasses creases things are a little
vague ER and then you can build in
whatever you want to see with a a little
more vagueness in there as this gets
higher resolution things are gonna get
awfully precise right and you like that
and it's clear whoa
we I nearly died as a graduate student
in an Ivy League school in the United
States in 1995 because an MRI was too
expensive I didn't know I needed one I
was pretty entrepreneurial I could have
but you know people are dying because
they lack access to medical imaging the
death rate I was speaking to a family
that runs a huge chain of hospitals in a
South American country you said the
death rate due to cancer there's three
times that of the United States and they
cite the cost of medical imaging as the
number one reason for that and so yes
getting more resolution to see inside of
our bodies and brains is interesting and
understanding how we work and by the way
we're not the only thing with brains on
the planet seems an important endeavor
for the living world but it's not
without repercussions of how misuse
could it's interesting that resolution
is both sort of spatial and pixels of
getting down to bandwidth of light but
also time I remember when virtual
reality first came along if there was
any lag at all it was disgusting it you
threw up once the the light got down to
you probably can name the actual number
of microseconds then that was no longer
an issue yes so this closer and closer
to real-time seems like an important
part of the resolution is that right
yeah I can be blurry I mean if we're
using fMRI it's over for seconds and so
slow like thinking of images but like
how can you abstract the images that
you're thinking of or the music
obviously which is very temporal but you
can you can think of it in terms of
frequency space for example and then be
able to dump that as has been shown but
um we can dump visual images out of the
brain and and and slow-mo movies with
motion compensation and so forth it's
amazing as you start to build what you
can do with algorithm development but
also we can movies is interesting cuz
then you're talking about the change of
pace that you can do in terms of reading
the micro movement
and things like that that really is a
whole nother level of information as we
developed these dictionaries of how we
see I mean so much of the visual is back
here in a certain area we can go I res
back there and then on the temporal can
we got the dip
that's the sub-second dip before it
takes the whole and you only have to go
down a centimeter here I mean it's like
it's so much easier and then from an
ultrasonic perspective we can then do a
tighter focus because the penetration of
ultrasound is related to its frequency
and the frequency is sorry inversely
related to the focus size so as say 20
megahertz you can go down maybe 2
centimeters but you can focus to a
twentieth of a millimeter Joey first you
can pick up the light to tears please
Mika's rawski yes what do you think is
the best path to become an early adopter
of this technology they have to come
work for you or what happened yeah we're
hiring every we're hiring lots but so
we're making alpha kits for next summer
as a figure out our go-to-market plan
and then the following year or two later
we'll be able to ship and that's when we
will be able to support a lot more
people because our first alpha ckets
won't be products we won't have finished
the UI and the UX and the ID and all of
that we're really focused on the physics
and the signal noise ratio and adopt and
the scan speed and so forth and so for
early adopter yeah work with our company
or one of the companies were working
with we're trying to figure out how to
reach out to the community but we're a
small company and we're really focused
and so maybe someone else maybe you have
an idea and you're you're working with
these rats in the lab now and see a
little more about you know what reading
and they're eventually writing means
working with these animals what are you
actually sort of getting we're trying to
exceed the resolution of Mr
it proved that with a living animal
because we just made the pulse lasers so
we can do living animals so I took money
from Brook buyers early on and this is
relevant because he made me make one
promise to him he found me brought me
and he said it would be sort of kleiner
perkins but it's actually four letters k
PCB he's the be in kind of Birkin sneak
came and got me into his office and says
look I want to invest and brought me a
nice check and he made me promise him
one thing I wouldn't experiment on
myself or any of my employees
too bad I had already promised but I
have so we're doing the animals live
volunteers you're ready Oleg line up
can't do it I promise Breck so smart
event actually so uh yeah so we're in
the small animal facility and then we
got a thing from the FDIC saying we're
okay in humans we think it's perfectly
safe we'll prove it and we just got the
Pope that strobe lasers that enable us
to do this on living things so we're
just getting our first images on living
things right now
Zoe you describe this as a ski cap or a
wearable or bra or something like that
that seemed a little more about what's
actually involved in wearing a thing
which is going to get that kind of
resolution out of the brain so well one
thing is the hair and so there's a small
comb structure because the hair absorbs
light especially ok I'm just gonna say
it anyway with dark hair dark skin we're
testing that because black things absorb
light more than white things
so you're easier you've got less hair
I'm good bring it on advantage well I
know it's some fashion least nails now
to have no hair at all yeah exactly so
that's easy no but would do it'll work
for everybody so we've got this and you
put it on and it it the ultrasonic
things we so one thing I didn't explain
is ultrasonic on ultrasound is a
different speed in bone as opposed to
flash and so it distorts and so we
correct for that Distortion with other
ultrasonic probes looking at that so we
can focus and we focused as the shape of
that ultrasonic probe around and we
could pick it up with camera tips that
are literally camera tips that are being
made at more than a million units a day
that go into the world's smartphones the
ultrasonic chips are going mainstream in
the fabs now and we're making fiber
lasers that are very typical so we're
using what Asia Inc and the consumer
electronic supply chain is good for to
make these sub components that enable us
to make something low-cost that can fit
inside of a wearable we it can be a wand
as well and that might be better I mean
literally if you're going to give
something to a village long as both
projecting and reading is that the idea
yeah you can project and read and that
might be better in terms of hygiene
rather than a wearable if you're going
to share it across people mm-hmm
what kind of power demand is all this
after you do all that light and optics
well it depends so it's a modular system
on each of those disks so showed over
they had represent an ultrasonic chip
and a camera chip array mm-hmm a double
stack camera chip array that has logic
decoding in it and then a fiber optic
coming in and a like I plate that brings
in the reference beam to the camera chip
we can spread those out as many as we
want but you know the amount of depth
and resolution and is related to how
much light we can bring in and so we
envision a small medium and large lasers
so the large laser will draw more power
and
laser one place we want to get into
immediately as triage ambulance urgent
care right places that don't have the
power plant and so we definitely want to
be in the size frame that can work in an
ambulance power yeah I said what makes
me wonder is you know there's the sort
of the portable one there's the
ambulance one and there's the one in the
big expensive room in the hospital just
the lasers are different everything else
is the same
and we age' Inc likes to make lots of
exactly the same thing so that's why we
just buy more camera tips and more
ultrasonic parts the laser it's hard to
gang up the lasers because of the the
very stringent requirements we have on
the what's called the coherence it
sounds like a silly term but it makes
sure's all the waves are exactly the
same way of like the light within a few
megahertz which is a it's a like a
thousandth of a nanometer
no kind of coherence and so it's very
hard to gang up the lasers like that so
right now our approach is a small medium
and large laser we have a really large
laser that we've built that's um that's
big but it allows us to experiment
around and blast things and make sure we
can see the limits of the physics
mm-hmm there's the D scattering I mean
did holography early on and that's free
a transform and stuff like that yeah
your scattering out is that just a nice
off-the-shelf kind of thing now or is
that got to be pushed a lot further
so the holography is enabled basically
in the infrared by by two factors that
have come into being literally for 3d
scanning and for for Pokemon go and VR n
AR and that is they sound scary two
terms quantum efficiency which is light
in electrons out was seven percent in
the near-infrared until this year
you know it's seventy percent mostly
because you can unlike your iPhone with
a rather than a picture of Stuart brown
and now it has to be you and your
measured at 940 nanometers where you're
back there's this window between 700 and
900 nanometers where you're a
translucent blob of gelatinous blood and
look like a jellyfish
and then your backhoe peg at 9:40 that's
for your iPhone's working and unlocking
your phone it's got this laser light
it's sending out at 9:40 it doesn't
blind you it's low but the camera tip is
looking for the signal of that laser
light to catch the shape of your face
which means it's looking for a little
ripple on a sea of light in the room and
so what that is called it's a deep
quantum well and that's that's also what
we want because we're looking for a
little sea of ripples in the hologram
that we recall recording of the the
wavelength shifted light over the huge
sea of non wavelength they live like
that shifted light and so we can use and
most camera chips have red green and
blue color filters on it that doesn't
work in the infrared because no infrared
gets to that right so these small
changes so it's monochrome it's a
monochrome with a thicker silicon layer
so it can catch the with good efficiency
the longer wavelength of light that
costs whatever call it a billion dollars
to get it everywhere but it is
everywhere and it's shipping at a
million units a day in the thing with
consumer electronics industry mates and
so I saw that and I'm like you know I I
loved Pokemon go I actually played it
every day for a while but you know like
Pokemon go versus you know transform
medical imaging and a chance at
telepathy
well easy choice and that raises
question of the signal that's coming out
of this can you put on augmented reality
sunglasses and see through your mics
maybe but like why not just extract what
they're thinking why not communicate
visually there right right
is the best display actually because
I've made displays all these years we
don't want to have to wear anything
can't we just zap each other these
thoughts and images directly like
without covering our eyes people don't
like to have their eyes covered with
anything other than what we're wearing
yeah you're right about that
a question from Nick at longhouses
improved imaging of each other
her age this is what we're talking about
better models allow us to focus on more
new wants things do you think that these
models will ever be exhaustively
completely is there sort of levels of
nuance beyond which there's no reason to
go because you've got everything how
rich do these things want to get I guess
we don't know until we start to sample
it's always this analogy right peeling
the onion you think no you know just if
I could only have one megahertz right or
whatever you know like but no then
that's not enough for whatever picked
the amount of storage and so there's
always more things that you can do with
a more capability that's I think how
this town was built on the hardware side
with more Sun everybody just more
megahertz and more storage and so forth
and we'll figure out what to do with it
but you know it's possible that you know
history is good but you know that's what
science is trying to do is find out the
unknown through successive approximation
and so we're all interested in figuring
it out and understand anymore
so you've been in the thick for thirty
years of the advance of all these
technologies and all of these
applications and so on and as you're
advancing this one those will be moving
along too and how do you see sort of the
since you were looking I had on what
this particular technology has in the
way of a short or long and a very long
term future how about the whole array of
things that it is part of it is drawing
on the trillion-dollar industry and so
much itself is camping all these other
applications what's the range of
applications that is emerging what this
is part of it commutative applications
have Justin consumer like trying to say
I mean it's become a monoculture mmm-hmm
really like in 2008 the sky fell I was
living in Asia at the time and you know
the companies I worked with that we're
living at negative 30 negative 40%
margin I don't know if people remember
that I do very viscerally it was very
hard I had taken millions of dollars
from my friends to start a company I'd
left MIT every day I woke up thinking I
left on my t4 doing to do this it was
very hard
but what happened is one company
executed very well Apple with its
breakthrough product the iPhone followed
by that iPad and everyone else became
fast follower at ten years later there's
no real differentiation everybody's got
their candy bar phone and went replace
it in so what's next in consumer
electronics is is a good question so
there's been all this money spent on VR
and AR it's not succeeding for lack of
investment that's for sure I mean how
many billion dollars it's a lot I have
some stronger opinions maybe privately I
could share but as a former facebook and
go like executive in require it just ya
know I'm just not gonna go there so yeah
so um we could do much better but you
know aren't there more interesting
things we can think of to do with
technology and aren't they you know so
right like wow do we fix up the fake
news in this sort of weaponization of
social media if you will is one thing
but that's not long long term long long
term is you know it is I think we both
saw this quote from Joey this weekend
he's like well we think of humanity in
the future like mankind now like totally
discriminatory because there are all
these other living things and why are we
so focused on the humans for God's sake
there's all of these other things that
are living and don't they have rights
and I know I did that as I took the the
pig brain this weekend yesterday but
they throw away the Hat they kill the
pig for a bit like are we gonna you know
these are the sort of the questions of
how we deal with living rights and
environment and good can we get to
distant planets and and you know what
are we gonna learn and understand and
grow and all that all the way you know
why I live I to learn and how
interesting exciting things to do but
what are those we think this is part of
it to be able to see inside of your body
and brain in a thousand times deeper a
billion times smaller in a billion
billion times higher resolution and
because
there's so many zeroes there we don't
even have a business model yet which
gives us a lot of room people are just
happy for us to focus on the white-hot
risk of just making the thing and
there's a lot of a lot of use for it
mm-hmm but I don't besides that your
question what is the answer you what
you're a big thinker what is well it
probably relates to in relates my next
question which is your electrical
engineer you've been dealing with
hardware and the software that drives
the hardware for a long time now
suddenly you're in meat where you're
doing biology pretty thick that's most
of the people I know from the so-called
hard sciences quite it's a real jump to
get into the biological sciences because
it's such a different world it's a messy
world evolved world was not an engineer
of the world it's seems to consist
entirely of special cases yeah you can't
you know all this business of reverse
engineering the brain it was never
engineered so there's no reverse gear
for that what's that like for you to
jump into that mud patch well that
happened to me in 1995 when I got a
brain tumor
so I unwittingly as a means of
self-preservation learned all I could
about neuroscience and
neuroendocrinology just to survive as I
mentioned I take a dozen medications
every day since September 1995 if I miss
them I die so I think it's never far
from my thought in sort of investing
time and effort into it made sense so in
terms of neuroscience I've read and
widely and advocated also very profound
patient experience of being inside you
know I'm a doctor but not that kind of
doctor so that doesn't give you the
power in the system and sort of figuring
out how to get to outcomes that I mean
I'm sort of basically engineered a
better me I me I like
I actually like or is saying I liked me
that much before and it's sort of
interesting how you can change your
brain through these these chemicals that
I take and that's I've sort of perfected
I took like for five years in the late
90s and and really did that and then
tweak it every once in a while
so that suggests actually that the kind
of tweaking you're talking about doing
chemically basically now will become
increasingly possible yeah developing
will be tweaking our brains right like I
don't get gently because cortisol Peaks
in most people's bodies an hour before
they wake up on whatever time some
they're at or whatever cycle but not me
I don't make cortisol or adrenaline
without it I go into adrenal failure and
die but as a result it's really great
when you're working always halfway
around the world I was traveling I
literally went around the world every
three weeks for like six years and I
could function really well and whenever
timezone and then that's very useful if
although you know the environmental
impact is so we don't self-medicate or
yeah we self-medicate our brains all the
time with caffeine with alcohol with
these various things this is going to be
a whole nother mode of self adjustment
of brain activity I think a lot of the
medications for brain disease are that
sort of playing around dopamine and
serotonin and so forth but you know I I
was the only girl in the physics
department at Brown and I was the one
that got it was literally it was a good
kind of brain tumor but a pituitary
gland and that just fast forward that's
the thing that makes your hormones
neurotransmitters are a subclass of
hormones actually at a distance you make
like a dozen in your pituitary gland to
the thousands in your body and sort of
learning about how to hack those was
pretty fascinating and how illegal it
was to do at the time because even
though I was missing my pituitary gland
in 1995 it was illegal for me to replace
the chemicals that my pituitary gland
used to
just in age and sex appropriate dose
doses which I had a problem with I found
ways around it which I can't really talk
about that much but a lot of them are
now legal why was it building or I
forget because it was too expensive Oh
like human growth hormone for example
totally legal for children at the time
it was illegal for adults till is in a
lot of countries and and that like it
just it's just amazing how when you
start to look at that and the feedback
of it and do this sort of testing which
I did a lot of in the 90s and still do a
little bit but I mean I did I was doing
it like every week because I was a mess
like and I just think like we actually
can change like I think I'm like sort of
engine like I don't know like maybe like
what's been been really able to perform
on the job because like I changed my
neuro chemistry and have been very
effective so I'm sort of like I couldn't
compete in the Olympics or whatever but
you know like it's okay to get it like
you know for being smart like you know
we don't have rules against how we hack
ourselves for that which is great but
I'm kind of cheating and maybe see
yourself hacking is got a whole new
dimension so you never kind of an
interestingly specific question from
clabe Clayborne gaming says I suffer
from Canada's what it is awful could you
locate the source of the noise in my
brain and shut it down there's maybe
maybe we can famously uncurable you know
you got two stories it rates are much
higher because it just drives you crazy
over time and in the insidiousness of it
yeah so maybe I'm a friend of mine asked
me if we could do that and we're looking
into it because it looks like we can
read and write neurons can we pick out
the right but like that's FDA longer so
imaging is one we start to sort of zap
neurons and we need to do clinical
trials and so that's a longer frame for
when we can ship something safer but we
seem to have the tools in the toolbox
and so putting that in the form of a
product we can do
we're interested in getting something
that's safe out there for for triage and
ambulance and urgent care as as fast as
we can safely so that we can build up
the volume and then look at look at the
these so beyond brain things which was
mostly focused on this work - what if he
happens in cancer because the questions
of tumors and the blood flow and all
that sort of thing
in other aspects of the body with this
kind of visibility water other aspects
beside cancer of the body that might
become of interest is there something
athletes will be able to tune up with
ages internal bleeding like is your diet
changing your deposits in your your
arteries or Tullius grossest things with
pregnancy like the placenta is really in
an organ that grows when you're pregnant
and there's a lot of blood issues with
pregnancy and we're really good at
seeing blood there's no so photodynamic
therapy where we can I didn't show it
but we can also focus the light back
down not just the sound and that's the
hottest area and biophotonic
psychodynamic yeah we're mostly cut and
get deliver light but if you deliver
light to like a liver cancer or
pancreatic cancer patient you can lower
the chemo doses by 25 fold by adding
light and also there's this saying that
sunlight is the best disinfectant it is
literally true it's an antibiotic and
you can kill any kind of any kind of you
know what is that thing when you're like
get the flu and in Floyd
you can kill it not the flu that's but
like sorry I'm just trying to think of
can you a very automation directly car
pardon inflammation direct well you're
talking about you could go after
infection but not just touch the surface
but deep inside sounds like yes I'm not
invasively to so right now what's being
done with non with photodynamic therapy
is bringing in you know a fiber-optic
cutting a slit and moving it around in
your liver oh sorry liver or whatever
with inner organs and then then you can
reduce these chemo doses or kill
different bacteria without
antibiotics especially antibiotic
resistant and so we could do that
non-invasively by basically computing
the inverse of the hologram putting it
on a liquid crystal display and
illuminating the light to focus it back
down and we've done that in our lab with
these phantom tissues and the need that
we've developed and it does work and
we've we've built the rudimentary parts
of a new LCD that a liquid crystal
display that enables us to do that but
since we have the focused ultrasound
already we're just trying to figure out
what do we do to put together kind of a
first rudimentary kit rather than where
what we can do but the key thing is like
nothing in in medical imaging and very
few things in hospitals are made in the
consumer electronics manufacturing
infrastructure that's a monoculture from
the smartphones and the recovery of the
economic crisis Healthcare has gotten
super expensive how do we democratize
health care there's not enough doctors
and three continents in the world then
we have doctors here saying oh you know
like radiologists are worried about
their job going away because the machine
learning and AI is better and I you know
the Centaurs are supposed to be better
at radiologists come up to me all the
time telling me I'm taking their job and
I'm like but what about the Hippocratic
oath no do no harm if the AI is better
are you harming the patient there's not
enough doctors can't you work on the
corner cases because an expert with an
AI is much better and can they look at
this special class as globally because
we are all connected now at least with
smartphones and in cellular network if
not five G's coming right and so forth
some more bandwidth do we look at at
transforming medicine that way and why
is that so controversial the other thing
I also ask them is like have you ever
gotten to be in your entire life you
don't need to sleep but stay up three
days in a row like I'm not worried about
jobs for radiologists I know I should be
but like they're very smart very capable
very driven people who can help make
people mm-hmm and when I see coming with
all your genetic
and hundred exes and thousands actually
approvement is the cost of medical care
very search has been going up and up she
drop drop the whole goddamn thing not
just democratized toward everyone but
toward really affordable but let's and
then make it up on volume to get the
motivation for the businesses like let's
get great health care for everybody
right like even if it's more than
humanity and there's more money to be
made that way than just giving it to the
rich people perhaps more health care for
everybody thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]